well if there's one thing you can say
about me it's that I care passionately
about my health and my beauty that's why
I've come to Korea town to the we spa an
authentic Korean spa I brought with me
Steven Yeun international star come on
in here don't look so scared okay yeah
I'm good yeah all right
yeah this is good you look worried yeah
you battle zombies for a living you you
fight the undead yet you seem worried
about coming to to a spa if you want
walk around here naked no one told me
that was part of Christmas rink I've
never been naked so what did you just
give me right here you just give me
other that's a large that's your t-shirt
wear when you go to Colette floor oh
there's a co-ed area yes if they're
going to be other women around what are
the rules may we speak to them you can
mingle whatever you want there's no
sexual activity or you will be banned
banned for how long like a life ban
who's in line the policies you have 75
thousand rules here in nine different
languages nowhere does it say anywhere
Stephen mm-hmm this doesn't say anything
about sexual activity yeah guess what
it's gonna take you 24 hours to get that
new leaflet name in the meantime
[Music]
well
can you read Korean what is this thing
since it's an English
this is Jonathan Jonathan works here at
the we sponsor correct
just like you put your clothes in your
locker although all the clothes
can I wear jeans down here no no jeans
okay pick this no one's wearing in jeans
in there so if you're the only one you
know you're gonna be looking awkward now
be in jeans and they'll have their dicks
hanging out so I think
[Music]
[Applause]
Stephen and I are now in a sauna it
sucks you in the nude men you see throat
just just calm okay that's why he can
tell that I work out oh you too a chill
where you're not looking at me look at
me look at me look at me
[Applause]
you think it's funny when one naked man
I squeeze the breasts of another funny
okay it is fun yes when you went to
watch yeah I got a lot you ain't white
uh-huh one man squeezed but you like to
watch what you hear in the Kennedy for
him again right there do you like this
[Applause]
becoming aroused what are we doing now
now you're gonna go into the code tub
[Applause]
it's nice now just hold me
Jonathan tell us what happens now so you
guys never gonna get gonna scrub my
scrub is a full body scrub yes this is a
disturbing setup is this when they do
dolphin autopsies is this going to hurt
yeah it is hurt
sadist you like to hurt people
gives you pleasure yes
meet mr. Lee mr. Lee mr. Lee thank you
whoa
okay that's high that's high no those
are freckles no stay on those but if
mrs. Lee duty last night that skin
that's been on me since Jimmy Carter was
president mr. mee I've lost all feeling
battalion is in the mountains
see coming miss tilly are you doing
no this ball
Miss Julie harder what happens next
so what are submitting over to the
gingiva what is Jim Jim Bob Jim divine
means solace saunas okay let's go
chinkyu Bob
213 degrees people carry pizzas in here
unquote come out they have a freshly
cooked pizza and then they're dead I'm
going in okay I might stay in for a long
time huh
they took my skin and now I want to
sleep forever
this one this one actually is really
good I think when you're in a room
filled with cocoa puffs hello hello are
you okay are you feeling good
do you know who conan is no idea who I
am
have you ever seen a show called Walking
Dead no what's your favorite TV show
what TV show do you like okay so you
don't know who I am you don't know who
Steven is everyone loves waymond hasn't
been on the air do you like it does it
make you laugh same joke over again like
oh my god all my wife's mad at me oh my
brother's taller than me oh I gonna do
what am I gonna do right
that is the best Ray Romano impression
I've ever seen may I move closer to you
or would you rather I did not get
nervous don't trust yourself Hey
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh well that was our day at the we spa
in Koreatown
thanks for joining me this was fun no no
it was not fun but it was awful it was
it was painful and for me I think life
shortening my skin is really smooth I
won't be dead within 48 hours
thank you yeah for showing me this and
I'm starving you wanna get lunch yes I
know awesome place stillness yeah no
thank you they took my skin and now I
want to sleep forever
a song
[Music]
Oh
No
[Music]
[Applause]
we got a great show tonight
you